mardi gras may be over but last weekend
brought another vibrant celebration to
the streets of new orleans super sunday
is the day when african-american
revelers known as mardi gras indians
parade through town in their eye-popping
handmade suits for more than a century
they and other black people were kept
from taking part in traditional fat
tuesday celebrations but now they're out
of the shadows in fact my people a song
celebrating the indians is nominated for
a grammy award at next month's ceremony
i had a chance to meet members of the
group and look into their fascinating
history
it is a living theater of art and
culture
a competition of style and dress that
compares the craftsmanship of neighbors
from one community to another
elite groups calling themselves the
mardi gras indians
once i come out
and i see my peepers
at the air and they are ramming and
ready to go it gives me the energy
chief howard miller leads the creole
wild west chief daryl montana the yellow
pocahontas hunters two tribes of more
than 40. it hasn't come out we gathered
in congo square for centuries a meeting
ground for african americans who
practice their traditions you can't like
it
you gotta love it
until the day you die
and that's what it takes
you can't fake it
this carnival of color showcases suits
designed feathered and beaded over nine
months
but it's also a forkloric moment of
storytelling
this is what
we do debuting to audiences fat tuesday
morning
and then again on st joseph's day and
super sunday weeks later
and how much does that suit weigh
well maybe about
75 80 pounds
through it all what's happening to your
body
oh it is uh cramping up being in the
fight
your body so if we're gonna make that
full journey a walk that we we do we
have to be spirit connected because
that's what's to carry up your the
spirits the repetition of the
constant chance over and over and over
that's what bring you and carry you
the big chiefs of two different tribes
start with song a ceremonial dance
and challenge demanding that the other
chief bows and pays respect
and the queens they're now helping to
lead the tribe
we say things now and we feel things now
that relate to
the culture and to the neighborhood and
and to the other girls that see us
not as just
a
complimentary piece
but as
a symbol
to look up to and something to be
the tradition of gratitude dates back to
the mid-19th century
when runaway slaves found refuge with
native american tribes who themselves
suffered persecution that's saying thank
you for helping us
and it's done with pride dr maurice
martinez has chronicled that history for
more than 50 years in both his book and
documentary black indians of new orleans
carnival by itself the meaning of
carnival day topsy-turvy day
anyone could be anything
we're gonna meet everybody
they wanted to maintain their dignity as
human beings i'm a man
i'm the big chief
i won't bow down on that dirty ground in
the days of segregation and even after
masking allowed an ability to walk with
pride when many new orleanians face the
humiliation of racism did you ever
expect to be in here no i never my
wildest dream i never this mardi gras
season mardi gras indian culture was on
full display at the historic new orleans
collection we had to betray the native
american to be ourself because here in
the south everything about african was
forbidden couldn't talk about it
throughout its exhibit making mardi gras
the museum hoped to rectify decades of
discrimination and neglect
rex king of carnival one of the earliest
parade organizations once discriminated
against blacks jews italians and irish i
think it's a big note of equality that
we have a mardi gras indian suit next to
rex lydia blackmore is the decorative
arts curator it's hard to learn about
mardi gras indians for a long long time
they didn't want you to learn about what
they're doing it just wasn't the thing
to study for a long time because of
racial beliefs and racism in academia
and then a big push from within the
community to document their own
traditions i mean if you think of the
wild chapatulis and their recordings of
their music i mean great funk music of
the 1970s they started doing more to
preserve their culture
[Applause]
much of that began with big chief tootie
montana who passed his reign to his son
my father was a good great teacher my
playbook is different than a lot of
other guys you see just when a certain
time of year come you know i just feel
it as i'm supposed to start sewing he's
memorialized in stone at congo square
today i honor my chief there's not a
time out mass i don't go to his home and
kneel down in front of his door you know
giving me his credit i love my chief
honestly regardless of what had happened
to between us and the tribe i'd love
that man
[Applause]
victor harris once masked with him
before starting his own tribe as the
spirit of faiya
his suit takes on a more african style
an evolution he believes will keep this
legacy alive this is about the people
it's about my neighborhood my community
this is about the world for me
and the world has come to appreciate its
splendor
it represents for the young people young
black kids african-americans they're
role models for us it's something that
is revered
it's something that allows
one to feel a sense of worth sense of
freedom
the spirit chooses us once you take part
in and see a culture
and the spirit grabs
certain ones and won't let them go i
must say it is that
many are called but few are chosen and i
believe that we were the chosen one
first a big shout out to sierra morris
who produces
and laura pachadza who who edited it you
know this tradition has been going on
for well over a hundred years
they are now getting the recognition
they they deserve and their their suits
are all over the world um they did not i
mean it takes a lot of money to put
these suits together the new orleans
historic collection
is also um teaching classes with chief
howard miller leading those classes so
that he can pass it on to the next
generation so a lot of really great
things are coming out of it now money
and strength they weigh seventy five
eighty pounds can you imagine each one
of those outfits
in those suits wow i i love uh daryl
montana's comment you can't like this
you've got to love it until the day you
die it is a lifelong commitment they
loved it amazing beautiful